do have a bone to pick with you though
go ahead you're you're bit about F-150s
and pulling like the mirrors in and
stuff I have an F250 so like does that
also apply cuz I have to pull my mirrors
in I just feel like those are the least
introspective people on the planet
because people that drive trucks they're
always like they're always so mad about
the gas but it's like well you drive the
largest recreational vehicle
available every time they get out of the
truck they tuck the mirror in it's like
why not instead of tucking in why don't
you take a good long hard look in
it
and reflect that made so many people mad
and they're like oh you don't work with
your hands I'm like uh okay okay
hilarious and I'll tell you like 40% of
the time when I pull my miror and I
think about your joke I mean just Rel I
mean it is really just about my dad and
he has a GMC so you know that's just
where that came from and what is the
joke instead of pulling it in why don't
why don't you take a good long hard look
in it you know and
reflect